[Music]
a lot of people are still talking about
cams postgame press conference he's been
smiling and dancing all season long he
was very different cam last night he
pretty much shut down reporters and then
after a very brief amount of time he
just got up and he walked off check it
out if you haven't seen Cam Newton more
like Fig Newton
[Applause]
you know his name's Cam Newton and then
I just said yeah I dig Newton instead I
heard what you said it's time for
Conan's post joke press conference
[Applause]
we just have a couple of questions right
what happened out there
tried to try to do a joke and it didn't
work
your minds we came out of the clip just
was you know but like Cam Newton and
then made me think of Fig Newtons and oh
why did you think calling Cam Newton the
cookie was going to get laughs I don't
know bro do you feel like you let down
the show made a hit it hit a joke what
do want me to say you know it's made a
deal is there any talk about TBS maybe
trading you to another network now
[Applause]
nice thanks for coming let's just put
Conan's whole Fig Newton thing behind us
now we're gonna be right back with ray
romano and maybe we'll be lucky he'll
bring his friend bob parmesan Oh